FEMALE SPEAKER: The second
part of our day today.
Happy to kick off this broader
discussion on issues of gender
equality empowerment,
falling on a conversation
that Aimee and I started
here, and I honestly
can't imagine a more
qualified group of women
to be having this
conversation with.
It's a pleasure to
welcome you all to Google.
I thought rather than trying
to have everyone introduce
themselves, I'll run through and
just give a quick introduction
of who we have here on stage.
All of their bios
are available online
at makemyvoicematter.org.
So if you want to read
any more about them
or hear more about
their work, that's
the place you can check it out.
So you've obviously
already met Aimee here,
Aimee Mullins, with a few
labels-- actress, athlete,
advocate.
But none, really just Amy we
already talked about that.
To her left we have Hala Kazim.
Hala is a counselor,
artist, author,
and the founder of Journey
Through Change, which
is a new concept that she's been
working on that provides people
with support, advice, and
help through tailored services
and walking and hiking
destination tours.
She features regularly
as a guest speaker
on challenges facing women,
particularly in the UAE.
So Hala, so glad to
have you here today.
Thanks for traveling
to be with us.
To her-- the other
side of her-- I'm
going to not do the directions
correctly for the stage
directions.
We have Oisika
Chakrabarti, and she
is the Senior
Communications and Media
Specialist at the UN Women.
UN Women is dedicated to
gender equity empowerment,
and she has been with the
United Nations for 11 years
guiding media partnerships,
engagement, public information
around the UN.
And prior to that was herself
a filmmaker and broadcast
journalists in South Asia.
So obviously brings all those
qualifications to her role.
Down the line from her,
we have Arlette Nkurayija.
Arlette is the
President of Women
and Children Embassy
Foundation based
in Canada, where she advocates
and focuses on issues
of African women both
in Africa, as well as
people who have
immigrated to Canada
and helping them to settle.
She's obviously
an expert in that,
because she herself
was born in Rwanda,
and after the 1994
genocide chose a path
to creating a better future.
She moved to Italy, Montreal--
fluency in five languages.
She's now able to
use her law degree
and is currently working as
a lawyer for Talk Enterprises
and Talk Marketing.
Arlette, thank you
for being here.
And then finally on the end,
we have Melissa Goodman.
Melissa is the Director
of the LGBTQ Gender
and Reproductive Justice
Project at the ACLU
of Southern California.
She has been with the
ACLU for quite some time,
and I was very
excited to meet her,
because she led New York's
successful effort to pass
Marriage Equality Statute.
And then served
as the co-counsel
on the Windsor
versus United States
case, which eventually was
the case that the Supreme
Court held in determining that
the Defense of Marriage Act
was unconstitutional.
So Melissa, pleasure
to have you here today.
Well, let's get this
conversation started
with a relatively broad
question for someone
who I think thinks a lot
about issues globally.
Oisika, could you
just talk a little bit
about what do we mean
by gender equality,
and when we think about where
we are today in the world what
progress still needs to be
made, and why are we talking
about this issue still today?
OISIKA CHAKRABARTI: Sure,
that's a great question.
And firstly, thank you
for hosting this panel.
This is a great
conversation to have,
and of course a topic very,
very close to my heart
and all our hearts, I guess.
So what do we mean
by gender equality?
We mean a world
where men and women
are equal whether it's
politics, whether it's sports,
whether it's economy, whether
it's access to health care,
in all aspects of life.
For some people, let's say
for my four-year-old daughter,
she thinks gender
equality is a given.
It is something
that she completely
believes that she's
in no way different
from my six-year-old
son, because she's not
treated differently.
And she doesn't believe she has
anything up the road where she
will be treated differently.
She's having a ball imagining
everything is equal.
And as a parent, I hate
to think of that day
when it will suddenly click
in her head that it's not so,
that gender inequality is
entrenched in our society
no matter where
you look-- economy,
politics, sports,
access to health care,
the amount of leaders we have.
And it's not to
say that we haven't
had progress there has been a
lot of progress over the years.
Today there are many more women
and girls in primary education
than ever before
in the world, there
are many more women in
politics today than ever
before in the
world, and there are
many more women in the economy.
They're working, and
they're in paid employment.
But the progress
that has happened
over the last few decades
is too slow, uneven,
and just not enough.
I say that, because
today one in three women
are going to be subject to
violence in their lifetimes.
Across the world there
are only 25 women
who are prime ministers
and presidents.
In the corporate sector, since
we are in the Silicon Valley,
we can't refute the fact
that there are only 25 women
CEOs in the Fortune
500 companies.
There is a 24% wage difference
between men and women.
And even as we speak
right now women are dying.
Women are dying
every single day.
800 women die every
single day just trying
to give life, as in childbirth,
from preventable diseases.
That is unacceptable,
and that is
why we say gender inequality
is still entrenched,
and every single day we have
to work towards changing that.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Melissa, I think it
would be interesting to hear--
I think sometimes here in the US
we think, oh, we've
made so much progress,
and these are
perhaps issues that
are more prevalent in
other parts of the world.
Could you talk a little bit
about the US perspective,
at the ACLU, some of the
things that you'll really
are focused on right now?
MELISSA GOODMAN: Sure
it's such a big question,
too, because there's
so many things.
And one of the things I have
the privilege of working on
at the ACLU is our
gender equity work.
And I guess much
like Oisika, there
has been tremendous
progress, but there
are areas where there are still
just structural differences
and problems.
So I'll give you my top six.
The first I would say, and
it has a few components,
is really that the continuing
structural barriers,
stereotypes, and
unconscious bias
that really still hold
women back in the workplace
and translates into
less economic power.
This is a global
problem, but also
a problem in the United
States, and there's
a lot of pieces to it.
We are largely far from the
time where women are officially
treated differently or
shut out of jobs altogether
in the United States.
Though I will note, the ACLU
actually does have such a case.
We are actually
still challenging
the exclusion of women from
combat positions in the US
military.
So it does still
happen, but largely
now you what you really see is
unequal employment opportunity,
and in particular
a real difference
between who enters
the workforce and who
elevates to management
and to leadership.
And it's really
about stereotypes,
assumption about women's
abilities and interests,
what an ideal worker or
success really looks like.
In our mind when
we close our eyes,
we think of a man for
a lot of these things.
And it's been proven that traits
that really make men powerful,
and strong, and respected
in the workplace,
are the very same traits
that make women less
likable and subject
actually to poor evaluations
in the workplace.
So there's that.
There's continuing systemic
pay inequity, as Oisika noted,
in the United States.
A big thing for us
that we're working on
is, and I'm only still
on the employment part,
is the fact that in
the United States
we literally have no
supports for working parents.
And that is not
just a female issue.
That is a male and female
issue, but the cultural reality
in our country is that
the burden of that
falls disproportionately
to women.
And we have no
paid family leave.
In fact, only 12% of workers
in the entire country
have access to
paid family leave.
I was just looking up the
statistics again today,
and was horrified when I read
again that 33% of new mothers
takes zero time whatsoever
after their child is born.
And that's terrible
as a cultural reality.
43 million workers
in the United States
don't even get paid sick days
to take care of themselves
or their child when they're ill.
And we have no system
of affordable daycare.
So that's just a few of the
things in the employment
sector.
Just a couple more things
that we work on-- I
agree that the gender
gap in politics
is a tremendous problem and
it exists the United States,
and not just other
countries that we often
think we're better than.
Not true.
There's a tremendous amount
of gender-based violence
and harassment.
I just heard last week that
domestic violence calls
are the single largest
category of calls
that the police in the
United States get every year.
Women are losing their ability
to make personal decisions
about whether and when to
have a child at alarming
rates in the United States.
Politicians remain completely
obsessed with interfering
with that highly personal
decision about whether to have
a child or have an abortion.
And that is something
we're seeing all the time.
We're seeing girls are still
often getting education that's
full of gender stereotypes.
And finally, I would be remiss
if I didn't also point out
problems with our
criminal justice system,
and the gender impact that has.
In the United States our
criminal justice system
over-incarcerates women for
low-level, nonviolent, often
petty, poverty related offenses
at much higher rates actually
than men.
And this just creates
a continuing cycle
of economic dis-empowerment,
and it separates families.
There's 1.3 million children
living in the United States
right now with
incarcerated mothers.
So these are just a few of the
things we think need fixing.
FEMALE SPEAKER: It
sounds like you'll
have a job for a while Melissa.
MELISSA GOODMAN: Yes,
and for better or worse,
that is the truth
FEMALE SPEAKER: I think one of
the really interesting things
that we have represented
in this panel
are just these different
perspectives on this issue.
Hala, I think your
perspective would
be particularly interesting.
How do you think
about empowerment
in the context particularly
of the UAE in the Middle East,
and how might perception
of that context
perhaps differ from
reality in your experience?
HALA KAZIM: First thank
you for having me well
I think one of the main
thing I want to clarify
is the media has given a very
negative idea to the world
about the Arab world.
And I'm not defending
it, I'm just
saying that the reality
in some countries
are very different than
what is it really shown.
The gender equality is
one of the main things
now UAE has-- I think six
months back [INAUDIBLE]
has [INAUDIBLE] has
announced a law that there
is gender equality
between men and women
at work in the
society and [? all. ?]
And does it's really
apply in reality?
Well it's around the world.
When we really think, if I
will be very frank about it,
it's a man's world.
And that's reality is, and
I think we women did that.
We have a part of that
giving them so much power.
Now it's nothing wrong.
We are not in a competition.
I always say, it's not
like I have to be equal,
like everything.
There are things I know I'm
not able to do like a man,
and a man cannot
do like a woman.
That there are a lot of things
that we can do the same.
Like in our countries,
the salaries for example,
we are equal.
In America, it's 50%.
So if a man takes
$10,000.00 a month,
exactly the same
$10,000.00 for a woman.
It doesn't matter
the age, or whatever.
It's very much equal
in that positions.
Mostly I would talk about
yes, you know Arab world,
but you have to understand
that Arab world are not
as everybody sees it
that it's one country.
It's so many different.
The Egypt is thousands
of years of history.
Well, when we come to UAE, we
have done the UAE United Arab
Emirates in 42 years only,
and whatever we're doing,
I think it's miracle.
Lately [INAUDIBLE] and
they have made a law
that a divorced
woman, a single woman,
gets a free land like a man.
And we do get, all
of us, I mean I'm
an example of having a free
land and an interest free loan
for 25 years.
Now this goes to all the
nationals of our country.
So different countries
have different laws,
but I'm not saying we are
living in a la-la-land.
There's no perfect
country, but we are trying.
And I think I would give
that at least to our country,
that we are trying
our best, or we're
doing our best to at least
take care of some shortcomings
of what this reality is.
So I think women's
empowerment is
getting stronger and stronger.
I think people like all of
us, there are thousands of us,
that can do some changes.
And if I can, I'm an example
of a woman that from UAE
from Dubai, and
I'm sitting here.
And that shows that we
are given the chance
to do a lot of things.
So it's, you know I don't want
to compare Arab countries,
because I always say like when
an Egyptian grandmother was
going to the university, my
grandmother was illiterate.
It's so different I cannot
compare, but we're catching up,
and I think it's around
the world everybody's doing
their best.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Hala,
you touched on something
that I think is interesting,
and something that we've
seen more conversation about
this year in particular
with the HeForShe campaign,
which is the role of men
in this movement.
You mentioned you know
women in some ways
have put ourselves
in this position,
or men have put us
and I think it's interesting
as we talk about empowerment.
Aimee and I earlier spoke
about self-empowerment
versus being empowered
by some other entity.
Open to anyone's
thoughts I think really,
but just what is the role,
and should be the role of men
in this movement?
And then I think that
the next question is--
what should we as
women be doing more
to support each other in
achieving the goals that we all
have for gender equality?
Anyone want to-- Arlette?
ARLETTE NKURAYIJA: I will say
just to start where you are.
And that means everyone.
It doesn't have to
be a big speech,
or some panel like
we doing right now.
It helps, but I think it's
better to just keep it simple,
and start where you are,
and look around you.
Look at the women
around you, and it
could be a little conversation.
It could be to ask how they are.
It could be to just understand
what they are going through.
And in that way
small things that
make a difference in
every woman's life,
and to be able to tell
them that they matter.
Then you can go and
do bigger things,
like education and
talking about it.
Then that's OK too but I think
sometimes we think that we just
need to do things, and we are
thinking I should do this,
I worked with this.
And it doesn't materialize,
because you are thinking
and you are planning.
But you can just start and do
something small, but effective.
OISIKA CHAKRABARTI:
Just to add onto that,
and I completely resonate
with what Arlette said.
So you mentioned the
HeForShe campaign.
So that was an initiative
that came from you
and women, the campaign itself.
Last year, one if our goodwill
ambassadors, Emma Watson,
the supremely
talented actress, she
launched this HeForShe
campaign which
is exactly what
Arlette was saying.
It's a call to men
and boys to engage,
not through an
organized movement,
but in their everyday.
I mean as a father, as
a brother, as a son,
as a supervisor at
work, at an artist
who is doing an exhibition.
So just engage in
your everyday life,
I mean to bring up your children
on a foundation of equality.
That's what every father can do.
To stand up for discrimination
against your colleagues
when you see that
in your office.
So it was a way to make every
man and boy across the world
sort of stand up,
and take a pledge,
and say OK, so I'm
going to do this.
I'm going to make
sure that the women
and the girls
around to me are not
subjected to discrimination.
HALA KAZIM: I think if we
talk about how do we do it,
it's from inside.
You have to believe
that you can.
A woman should
believe in herself.
And I think one of
the very main thing
to help this is when
you raise your children.
I have five sons, and they
have no issue with women
to be even better than
them, or equal to them.
So I think it all starts with
us, not really from outside.
AIMEE MULLINS: I
would echo that, Hala.
I think for all
of us, we'd become
aware of where we have
little prejudices,
or we act in discriminatory
ways without even realizing it.
I think it's incredible to
just wake up and understand
that even if you think you are
as progressive as you think
you might be, there's
always a place where
you're holding onto a pattern
that is probably outdated.
It doesn't serve you anymore.
It definitely doesn't
serve the person
who is being boxed or
limited or categorized
and in a limiting
way, because of that.
So I think the most exciting
thing about that HeForShe
campaign, and similar
awareness campaigns
about it, that you know
when feminism started,
there was a component of
it that I think necessarily
was rooted in anger at
a sense of injustice.
And not just a
sense of injustice,
but real, experienced injustice.
And now that we're a
few generations on,
I think the idea
that to be a feminist
is to want equal treatment
of the sexes, you know,
all of them.
FEMALE SPEAKER: That's right.
Sorry, did you want
to add something?
Hala you mentioned
women and violence,
and I think Oisika you mentioned
some of the numbers there.
And I think for people,
women especially,
but people, anyone who's in
those challenging situations,
finding empowerment in
those really tough moments,
in people experiencing
daily violence or abuse--
What messages, and how have you
thought about- or in your work
as you are all
interacting potentially
with people in those
situations- how
do you think about people
there who are in that really
low place of subjugation?
Helping them to find
moments of empowerment,
what advice would you have?
ARLETTE NKURAYIJA:
It is to go back
to every single person
as an individual.
Everyone is unique,
and it will be
pretentious to think that
because you have an experience.
Or you have been
through so much,
that it's going to
help someone else.
It could, but it's not.
So it has to be always
about the other person.
And it has always to
be also about you,
because-- I will
give an example.
I am a survivor of
genocide, and I really
don't like to say
that about myself,
because that's how people
sees me: as a survivor.
That I feel like
I am human being.
What happened was hard.
It was a situation that I didn't
cause, but that helps me now.
When it was happening,
I couldn't get it.
And if someone
would have come then
and told me because they
went through something,
it will help me, I will
have not resonated then.
So I feel like every time
someone needs, whatever
they need, help, inspiration.
You can always go from where you
are and tell them your story,
and tell it in a way
that is true to you,
and sometimes going to resonate
with them, sometimes not.
But you have to understand
that it's not about you,
it's about them.
And if you are able
to help someone
you really have to remember
that the uniqueness has to come
from them back from you.
But sometimes you need
also to be practical
because there is some situation
when needs active action.
And I'm thinking of
a woman in my work
that I come across
that are very sick.
And you need to treat the
physical disease first
to be able to have
that conversation.
So I think as I said
before, to start where
you are is the most
important thing,
and to see what's going on.
Not to feel like
you have, of course
you have to make a difference,
but in someone others life.
MELISSA GOODMAN:
I was just going
to add though, that was
very powerful, Arlette.
I think the thing that I
like to try to remind people
in that situation,
is that no matter
how powerless they feel
in a particular situation
or in that particular moment,
to know that they still
have power.
And they still have
ownership over themselves.
And that they very simply
they are not alone.
Often it can help
to talk to others,
but unfortunately
we live in a world
where over a million women are
sexually assaulted every year.
Myself, also, as survivor of
some form of sexual violence.
I think that it's important
to say that, to own that,
and to tell people
that it's very hard,
but there is another side.
You get through
to the other side,
and there could be an
enormous amount of power
on the other side, and
that you're not alone
HALA KAZIM: I think
to me, what I really
would always say to any woman,
to learn to love herself.
And I think that's
where we don't know.
I think we abuse
ourselves, and we
don't take care of
ourselves, because we're
programmed that we should
always do something for someone.
And I think if you really
learn to love yourself--
like loving yourself, it
doesn't mean you're selfish.
It means you can
give people more,
because you take
care of yourself.
And when I meet people with
problems, they get puzzled.
What do you mean
I love yourself?
Of course I love myself.
And I'm like, "OK let's talk."
Then in the end she says,
"I know now, I don't."
And I say, "Loving
is not a handbag.
It's not a trip.
It's how you take care
of your well-being."
And that's all my company,
or my program I would say,
is all about: taking
care of yourself
in this journey of life.
And when you know how to
take care of your well-being
emotionally, physically,
this is spiritually,
and intellectually, everything.
And I'm not saying
going to be perfect.
None of us are perfect.
There are no perfection;
we would not be human.
But at least you
have the stability
of living a good life.
Then you really can put this
person with anyone, anywhere,
and they can do good, because
they're good to themselves.
AIMEE MULLINS: I think
this programming,
we've all touched on this,
starts very, very young.
I know that I've
become very aware
now that my friends
and peer group
are starting to become parents.
That I don't say to a little
girl "Oh, you're so beautiful!"
That will not be the
first thing I say to her.
It's a little rule
for myself, because I
find it interesting to hear the
things that were said to me,
or I would easily say
if I was babysitting.
You say things to
girls that you don't
say to boys in the sense
of be sweet, smile.
These things start from
a very young age where
it's about being palatable.
And I know from my
experience as an athlete.
Every year, a number of the
greatest female athletes
in the world gather in New York
City for the women's sports
foundation, which
Billie Jean King, who's
a wonderful advocate in many
areas, founded in the '70s.
And the athletes
do their own dinner
the night before, like at a
bowling alley kind of thing.
Really not competitive, right?
But we get together and we
go around the room first,
and it's sort of the
opportunity for the rookies,
the people never
been to that dinner,
to introduce themselves.
And it's extraordinary
how people, we're
talking about Olympic and
world record setting athletes
or professional
athletes, and how we've
been taught to dumb it down.
To not be threatening.
So it has become a little
ritual at this dinner
to be ridiculous.
Because it would start
by saying, "Yeah,
I play softball."
Oh OK, that's what
the rookie says,
and the next person
says, "Well, you know,
I set three world records."
And then the rookie goes,
"Well, I actually I am,
I do have the record
for the most--".
It's become, like in
this safe environment,
can you be wildly
celebratory of yourself,
and not have it equate to a
derogatory feeling of shame
or you're not being humble?
And it is sometimes these
little steps of that.
It just happened for me in
the bathroom here at Google.
A woman said to
me that she was--
we were talking
about sports, and she
said this she was doing
Olympic weightlifting.
And then she spent the next
five minutes telling me, "Well,
but for fun.
Well, more for fun,
not just for fun,
because you have to
work at it, but you
know I don't really
do it the way--"
And I listened to her
and I said at the end,
"You know, if you
were a guy, you
wouldn't have said any of that.
You would've just said, yeah,
I do Olympic weightlifting."
FEMALE SPEAKER: And
be very proud of it.
AIMEE MULLINS: And that's it.
Own it, and not have to
couch it so that you could
make it more palatable for me.
I think it's amazing.
But it's something I've become
aware of, because I do it too,
and we all do it.
And I just think that
becoming aware of, and having
little reminders to ourselves
and to our friends, I think
is just how we do start
to make that change.
HALA KAZIM: I think we're
brought up in the Cinderella
syndrome, that we have to
always wait for someone,
or we won't be complete.
Are programmed in a way
that you don't ask for much,
because you're not supposed to.
You should, you know,
in different culture
a woman should not raise
her voice or laugh loud,
because it's not proper.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I want to touch
on just one of the themes,
and this is really
interesting kind
of interplay the
conversation we're
having between really personal
choices that people make,
and then the structure in which
those choices kind of manifest.
And the interplay that I
think we're in a lot as women,
you feel empowered
one day and then
maybe you bump up against a
decision being made about pay
scale, or a decision
about leadership that
doesn't go your way, and all
of a sudden that's a step back.
That's a setback.
It does seem like a couple of
you touched on the leadership
imbalance, that there's
some things that
could be done by getting more
women into those leadership
decision making positions,
such that those norms
and cultures can start to
shift from a much higher level.
How do you think about the
right ways of going about that?
I know, Melissa, you're
working hard on this
in the film industry right now
with directors and producers.
I know Aimee is also working in
a different vein in that way.
So obviously that's one
particular industry,
but we see this
across government
across corporate America.
All the stats that
Oisika started this with.
How does that play
into this conversation?
MELISSA GOODMAN:
Sure, well I'll start
and try to be very brief about
it, because your question also
I think relates to
the last question,
and what we were all
saying about what
we're taught so early.
So I have been recently,
relatively obsessed
about gender bias in
Hollywood, in particular
looking at women directors.
And a lot of people
sort of asked me, like,
why is this something the
ACLU is paying attention to?
Why is this a civil
liberties problem?
And I think this
conversation is actually
the explanation of why.
One, it's a huge leadership
position in Hollywood.
But most importantly,
TV and film
are two of our most
important cultural products.
And the fact that literally
women are essentially
excluded from directing big
budget studio feature films,
and are seriously
under-represented in directing
television, it's not just
a civil rights problem.
Because you know,
note to Hollywood,
you do have to comply
with civil rights laws.
You are not exempt, even though
the culture is otherwise.
What we see on those screens has
a tremendous cultural impact.
And that's one of
the reasons we're
devoting so much time
and energy to this,
because our biggest cultural
product is overwhelmingly
being made by men.
The stories are male stories,
told from a male eye.
Women are depicted
through a male eye.
And I'm not saying,
you know, there's
not-- there's plenty of feminist
film and TV makers out there.
But studies have
shown, when you have
more women behind
the camera, not
only are more women depicted,
but the way in which they're
depicted, and the reduction in
stereotypes, the more speaking
lines literally that women have.
It's tremendously important.
So a lot of people think
like, why are you doing that?
That's one of the reasons.
So we look at industries where
women really are effectively
shut out from leadership.
And I guess the last thing
I'd say about that, only
because I'd be remiss, because
I'm sitting in Google, most
of our very powerful industries
here in the United States
do have tremendous
gender bias problems.
And tech is, as I'm sure many of
you know, you know one of them.
And when you were saying
leadership positions,
you know unfortunately, that
this stat I read recently
is only 9% of senior
management positions
in Silicon Valley
are held by women.
And we have to start
examining the disconnect
between the equality that we
have at the educational stage.
Women are generally in college
and even in graduate school,
you know, graduating
at equal rates.
But somehow when you look at
those leadership positions
the numbers drop
dramatically and we
need to start working on that.
OISIKA CHAKRABARTI:
Yeah, absolutely.
And UN Women also works
on this area of media,
because there's
this huge challenge
as Melissa was saying.
And we work in the news
rooms trying to expand
the dialogue on media.
But speaking about
leadership as a whole,
I think the challenge
is here in the US.
But it's also a challenge
across the world
where what's considered the
cohort of how many people
you need in Parliament to make
a move towards a different law
is 30%.
And most countries haven't
got anywhere close.
United States is 75th on that
scale, and it has about 20%,
whereas Rwanda has 67%.
So Rwanda is one of
those countries which
came after the reconstruction
where women became leaders,
because the men were
not there in government,
and politics, and everything.
But I also want to
come back a little bit
to the last question about
choice and self identification
and empowerment.
But what do you do when there
are no services to turn to?
Across the world, I might be
a domestic violence survivor.
I might think this is
dangerous, and it's
dangerous for me and my
children to stay in this house,
but where do I go?
And I think that also comes
from what Aimee was saying
earlier, how you're brought up.
For a person like me, I
would know that I have a job,
or I would know that I have
a father's household where
they would say just come back.
He's abusive?
Come back, it's fine.
But most people don't have
that luxury of choice.
So what do they do?
They look for an NGO
or a shelter to go to,
and there are none.
So when there are
more women leaders,
they also look for
these kind of services.
They try to move policy
towards having more shelters,
of having a place where domestic
violence survivors can go.
So in India where
I'm from, there
is a whole democracy movement
happening at the grassroots
level.
And the national parliament?
No, there are not many
women in politics,
and we are a very
long way to go to get
to the 30% I was talking about.
And the 30% is a benchmark that
was talked about 20 years back
at the Beijing conference.
So that's what I was saying,
the progress is too slow.
But at the grassroots level,
at the [INAUDIBLE] level.
What we called the
Village Council.
There is about a billion--
there is a huge movement where
women are becoming leaders.
And what are they looking for?
They looking for
the water should
be close to the
household, so that women
don't have to walk for
hours trying to get water.
They're looking for a primary
school in their village,
so that little girls
and little boys
can go to school in
a sustained basis.
Not just go one day and
then drop out the next day.
So when women
become leaders they
are also looking for
societal change, and not
just cosmetic changes
many of the time.
So we do need more
women in leadership
here in the STEM industry,
in politics, in government,
everywhere.
FEMALE SPEAKER: So I think
we are close to the time
that we should be
wrapping this up,
but we could obviously
keep this conversation
going for many hours.
I think it would be great to get
some final thoughts from some
of you on what change
you think is actually
possible in our
lifetime on this issue.
I think you've talked a little
bit about progress that's
been made, and sitting
here in Silicon Valley
we're always at the
nexus of the future.
And thinking about what with
all of the energy that we have,
and all of the leadership
roles that people have taken,
what change do we
really think could
be possible in this lifetime?
MELISSA GOODMAN: I feel like
everyone turned this way.
Oh my goodness,
so much pressure!
I feel like I'm
talking too much.
I'll just say I always sound
like a cynic on these panels,
but I'm actually
truly an idealist.
I wouldn't be able to kind of
wake up and do what I do every
day if I wasn't.
I really think, and
this is not necessarily
just through suing
people, it's not
the only thing the ACLU does.
But I feel confident
that, and I'll only
speak from a US
perspective at the moment
because I don't feel
qualified to speak otherwise.
I feel like we can
get-- I don't remember
the time period you said.
But I think some
of the changes we
need to make in the
workplace are attainable.
We're not, in a
cultural way, going
to erase eons of the way
we view gender roles.
We're not going to eliminate
unconscious bias tomorrow.
But I think we can
make practical changes
in the workplace that neutralize
people's unconscious bias
in the way that
we conduct hiring.
In the way that we evaluate
candidates for jobs.
In the way that we structure
our workplaces to be,
not only more supportive of
working families, but moving
towards a culture,
as Google does
espouse of kind of treating
workers as whole people.
That is something that is like
a radical, important gender
equality idea as well,
and very important.
And I think if we seriously
devoted time to doing that,
and thought about things like
family needs, and pay equity,
and the needs that workers
have outside of work,
I think we could
come a long way.
ARLETTE NKURAYIJA:
To me, I think
removing limitations one by
one, because there's so many.
And it's a matter of just
taking one at a time.
When you asked me
the question before,
it was after everyone
spoke, thinking
about the labeling of people,
and how you see someone
and you just want to
define that person.
And I was thinking
when also Aimee
was speaking about
when you see a girl,
and you want to say something.
And most of the time it's
about beauty or physics traits.
And then I remember when someone
that is very important to me
told me once, because you are
talking about liberating women,
and he said that
you are priceless.
And to me it was
empowering, and I'm
sharing, because when I
heard that it wasn't about--
and then it resonate because
it's not about what we do,
how much we own, it's
just being ourselves.
And when you are yourself,
you can go and ask that price
that you feel it's
fair or not, that to be
able to remove limitation, to
be able to see yourself, and be
true to yourself.
I think it's the
way to go to start
changing the empowering
one person at a time.
OISIKA CHAKRABARTI:
I mean I think,
and not just because
I work at UN Women,
but I'm very optimistic
about change.
I think the very fact that
we're having this discussion, ,
I mean, decades back, gender
equality wasn't on the public
agenda.
It wasn't in the private agenda.
But now we're talking about it,
we are all talking about it.
So I think that's
a huge change that
has happened over the years.
And then the other
part of this movement,
a disorganized movement,
unconscious movement,
is that all of us
can be part of it.
If 10 people from this room
went up to 10 people and say,
guess what I was at
Google and I was listening
to this talk about
gender equality--
I mean is it a question
mark, or should be a given?
Can we do it in our household?
And everybody can be
part of this movement.
And those 10 people
talk to other people.
So it's like little drops, but
that can create a whole change.
I mean just changing
that conversation
can have a huge impact
for the [INAUDIBLE]
household, or in the
community, or society.
But structurally also,
there are problems.
And that can only change
when it laws change,
implementation happens, and
when also attitudinally,
people change their
attitudes and mindsets.
For example it's 95 years
since women got the right
to vote in this country.
Isn't it time for
a woman president?
It's a matter of
changing attitudes that
has to happen for
society to change,
but I think there's a
lot of cause for optimism
HALA KAZIM: Well,
for me, I always
believe you should be
an example of a change.
And people could listen
to so many things,
and if they don't see
it, it's just talk.
And I talk about it personally
from what I have done.
I have changed so much
through so many years,
from a little girl in Dubai,
to a depressed, very depressed
woman, to a very
different journey
of self discovering,
and bringing Hala back,
and then looking at things, and
changing what's inside of me.
Now I think if every woman
talks from her heart,
and acts from her heart, we
are not fighting with men.
We are not in a race with men.
We are working with men.
I can't live without a man.
A man cannot live
without a woman.
They are my sons.
I have my father,
I have brothers.
So I wish we stop, like
you know, who takes more?
I have to take your
place, you have
to take-- I think there are
so many plenty of places
for all of us.
And I think if
they see it in you,
if they see the change in you,
in your mind, in your behavior.
And that's what I did in
Journey Through Change, telling
women: take care of yourself.
Take care of your inner
self inside of you.
Feel that you are worth it.
You don't need to
prove to anybody.
You know I always say it's so
good to have a man in my life,
but that's a bonus.
There are so many
things in life to do,
and yes, some people
say it's easy for me
to say because I have a husband,
and I have my sons, and all.
But I worked for them.
I worked to get that,
but even if I didn't, I
wish woman were raised to be
fulfilled, and a man to add
to it.
And I think I will
repeat and repeat,
it all starts with action.
If every woman
teaches herself first,
her children, her community, by
example, by spreading the word,
by awareness.
I truly believe, because
I did it in my community.
I did it.
I get hundreds and
thousands of messages
from women saying, because
we see how you did it,
we are doing it.
Because you are an example
of an action woman.
That's why when they
gave me the question,
I said I don't want
to prepare, I just
want to talk from my heart,
because I really want
to show what's inside of me.
And I think we are really, like
I'm talking about Arab women,
I've done more than
20 trips and I'm
done in this program for four
years, the most strongest women
I have ever seen.
And I'm not just saying that
and I know people think,
oh we are indulged, and we
have a very comfortable life.
Yes, we do.
I mean we do, what can
I say, I don't want?
You can't say that.
So if I have been given a
good life, I am grateful.
But what I have seen
in my trips from women
that is living a very
comfortable life, to stay
in three stars or
bed and breakfast,
and carrying their
own suitcases,
and walking 20 kilometer a
day, and come in Santiago.
That's where it all started
it for me, in Spain.
I think really,
really the change
it could be amazing for all
of us, for the new generation.
I mean, who would've thought
that all these different women
from all over the countries
can meet, and say what
they can say, and exchange?
We will never have
a perfect life,
but we will do our best
to have a good life.
AIMEE MULLINS: I
support and agree
with what all of these
incredible women have said.
I'm astounded by how much change
we can see in our lifetime.
And just yesterday
flying here, the person
in front of me in the
aisle in front of me
was watching the most
recent "Mad Max" film, and I
was excited.
And I didn't put my headphones
on, I didn't know the sound,
but I just watched for longer
than I thought I would.
Charlize Theron being
the lead of the film,
with a prosthetic hand,
and absolutely carrying
an action movie, and absolutely
it being, I don't know.
I just thought about, wow,
from "Terminator", "RoboCop",
to this.
It's absolutely happening
in our lifetime,
and I'm sure we could
say this across the board
when it comes to identity
with transgendered persons.
It's the rate at which
progress is happening,
and I think acceptance
and awareness, awareness
to acceptances is getting
faster and faster.
But with regards to women's
empowerment and equality,
it'll happen a lot
faster with men also
make it their priority.
I think men make
fantastic feminists.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Let's all thank
our panelists for being here.
[APPLAUSE]
GARY CATONA: OK, now
the excitement begins.
Aubrey Logan is going to
sing our hit song, "My Voice
Matters".
And as I said before,
these charities will
receive the benefit
of your generosity,
so please download song.
OK?
And there are t-shirts there
too, if you're interested.
But here is Aubrey Logan's
"My Voice Matters",
written by Nick Milo, Aubrey
Logan, and Gary Catona.
[MUSIC - AUBREY LOGAN, "MY VOICE
MATTERS"]